happening now honoring the lives lost in
last saturday's devastating crash nine
people died seven from the same family
madison kimbrough joins us live from
that vigil happening at the mlk junior
statue in north las vegas madison
[Music]
yeah tonight's vigil started at 4 30 and
you can see it's still going on behind
me governor sisolak and mayor lee of
north las vegas also spoke earlier
today's event honoring all who were
involved in the crash
minister stretch sanders organized this
candle light and prayer vigil as a way
to unify the community the fatal crash
that occurred just last saturday
involved 15 people many of which are
still recovering the zakaria's family
along with tanaka miller's family are
said to be attending miller was the
passenger in the dodge challenger that
was speeding county leaders saying
there's still so much that needs to be
done
and we see that
while we are standing here today people
are still making decisions to break the
laws that we have in place to keep our
communities safe
we have an impaired driving problem we
have an excessive speeding problem and
i'm looking forward to working with our
office of traffic safety in others
[Music]
the vigil is set to last until 6 30 but
with the amount of people showing up
there's a good chance it will last
longer this vigil is open to the public
and we plan on being out here all
evening bringing you the latest with a
full recap of this vigil at 11 o'clock
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now